être français se sentir français laïcité
et citoyenneté des notions parfois
difficile à aborder pour les habitants
des quartiers en politique de la ville
représentants d'associations élus et
acteurs sociaux ont participé à ce
séminaire en préfecture des yvelines
objectif trouver des réponses concrètes
à des questions parfois abstraites
certains jeunes nous disent la
république nous a parqué dans les grands
ensembles la république doit maintenant
s'adapter à nous quand on prend
l'histoire il n'y a pas de volonté
politique de parcs et des gens dans ces
quartiers au contraire on fait face à la
construction la reconstruction après
guerre on revient sur des éléments
factuels pour se réapproprier vraiment
ce qu'il en est écoutez les acteurs de
terrain au contact des habitants les
orienter mais surtout échanger sur leur
ressenti et leurs projets comme celui de
l'association mosaïque des quevilly elle
a réalisé un film avec les jeunes de son
quartier
ce projet là en fait que ce travail en
amont a récemment permis déjà de
découvrir - même s'il découvrait les
autres donc le vivre ensemble et le côté
humain qui est important surtout à
retenir
au quotidien on peut avoir des
questionnements autour de la laïcité
parce qu'on a vu que c'est des choses
qui font débat au niveau de la société
et le ramène à leur échelle
nous notre travail c'est de permettre
voilà de leur permettre de ne pas d'en
parler librement des changes et une
journée qui répond au plan de
mobilisation nationale du gouvernement
sur la politique de la ville lancé en
novembre
le compte rendu de ce séminaire sera
adressée à jacques mézard ministre de la
cohésion des territoires